[Música]
hablamos ahora de la revista de prensa
con rosa pérez es más de un rosa
bienvenida feliz jueves para ustedes de
muy buenos días empezamos hablando de la
noticia que nos llegaba anoche desde
perú también lo conversamos con nuestro
corresponsal en lima francisco zacarías
el cambio gabinete del gobierno del
presidente pedro castillo es rosa vamos
con la república el comercio y el país y
américa buenos dias raúl así es no hemos
podido hacer otra cosa que fijarnos
precisamente en como los medios peruanos
y también este medio más de abbas de
alcance latinoamericano se fijaban en
este cambio de gobierno así es los
empezamos con una república dice mirtha
vásquez juró como nueva presidenta del
congreso de ministros eso es si la
república precisamente defiende que este
cambio de gobierno particularmente la
sustitución ha seguido bellido por a
mirtha vásquez que recordemos es del
frente amplio no de perú libre pues
responde dice entre otras cosas a un
reportaje publicado en la publicación
epicentro en que se evidenciaba como
guido bellido estaba forzando la salida
del canciller
maúrtua y dice esta pues esta tensión se
sumaba también a denuncias de
acusaciones de agresiones machistas y
agresiones homófobas por parte del ex
primer ministro del primer ministro
saliente y dice por otro lado nos
fijamos también en que pues está el
cambio no en el gabinete responde a una
voluntad de castillo de facilitar y de
promover el diálogo y la gobernabilidad
en el centro pues esto de los del
gabinete de ministros seguimos hablando
de este tema pero ahora vamos con el
comercio rosa titula pedro castillo tomó
juramento al nuevo gabinete presidido
por mirtha vásquez sí exactamente vemos
que un poco los titulares son en esto la
noticia principal pero en el comercio
nos hemos querido fijar en precisamente
como destacan la reacción del propio
partido perú libre que impulsó la
candidatura de pedro castillo a la
presidencia y perú libre precisamente
tacha estos cambios de alta traición a
todas las mayorías que dicen llevaban
mucho tiempo esperando llegar al poder y
para ser precisamente atendidas y esto
nos lleva a precisar y el enfoque de la
siguiente publicación que es el país de
américa pedro castillo se aleja el
sector más radical para mantener a flote
a su gobierno
eso es raúl pues mira el país de américa
da por hecho que esta renuncia pues fue
forzada precisamente por pedro castillo
no por las tensiones que iban en aumento
constante entre pues el ex primer
ministro y el resto de ministros del
gabinete no y dice precisamente pues
en la cuestión estaba en que se veía no
la figura del primer ministro como
demasiada cercana al secretario general
de perú de perú libre vladimir el serrón
y precisamente dice es un suicidio
político que pedro castillo se
desvincula y de esta forma del partido
que lo aupó digamos a la presidencia y
dice el país es muy claro en eso fue muy
difícil para castillo llegar a la
presidencia recordemos que ganó las
elecciones el 6 de junio y no
digamos que fue condecorado como
presidente hasta el 19 de julio por
todas
denuncias sin pruebas que impuso el
fujimorismo dice pero lo más difícil
estaba por llegar y dice eso si este
miércoles pedro castillo ha dejado claro
que quiere ser el único responsable del
incierto futuro de su país rosa dejamos
ya este tema de perú a un lado nos vamos
ahora hasta eeuu vamos con de gharyan
dice soy médico abortista en texas mis
pacientes están desesperadas lo dice
samuel big man con todo esto de la ley
antiaborto en ese estado que está
ocurriendo rosa eso es raúl nos hemos
querido fijar en este testimonio en este
periódico británico the gardian no pero
que hace referencia a toda la
problemática que hay con la legislación
alrededor del aborto en el estado de
texas que como bien comentaba en los
noticieros está ahora mismo suspendida
pero que cuando entró en vigor según
defiende este médico que práctica y que
el aborto en este estado supone pues una
prohibición definitiva y prácticamente
total pues del derecho al aborto
entonces este médico samuel dyckman lo
que defiende la tesis que defiende es
como los determinantes sociales pues
crean desigualdades
el acceso a la salud y precisamente pues
a un aborto seguro y dice precisamente
la mayor parte de sus pacientes dice son
personas de clase obrera personas
racializados con pocos recursos que por
el contrario de los artesanos con muchos
recursos de los textos ricos que van a
poder permitirse si quieren desplazarse
a otro estado para someterse a un aborto
las personas pues pobres no van a poder
hacerlo o bien van a tener que continuar
con embarazos a veces no deseados él
pone el ejemplo de una paciente suya por
ejemplo a la que le practicó un aborto
días antes de que entrara en vigor esta
legislación y que tenía un embarazo
fruto de una violación un aborto que
ahora no podría practicarse entonces
defiende que habría que abogar por una
legislación federal que protegiera el
derecho del aborto dentro de un marco de
derecho universal a la salud pues rosa
gracias a por toda esa información nos
vemos mañana con más titulares de la
prensa internacional nos vamos ahora con
nuestro primer invitado del día